How and where
you sign the Republican integration contract?
It is to note
that the Republican Integration Contract
is prepared by Luffy
who,
during a personalized interview,
therefore individual,
she presents it to you during this same interview.
Moreover
is the one I was telling you about last time,
we will do 1 language evaluation,
so we go all out
simply see if you speak French or not.
1 time
that you sign the Republican integration contract,
well,
you are committed
to respect the principles and values of the
French Republic
and above all to follow seriously
and attend the training courses that are prescribed.
The contract is concluded for a period of one year,
so there is 1 language training,
there is 1 formation,
uh,
civic and citizen who is mandatory.
Moreover,
to motivate
people
to sign this Republican integration contract,
and the attribution of the residence permit,
rather annual,
so two-three or 4 years,
is conditioned
to the production of the 4 diplomas of the office.
In fact,
when you renew
your 1st residence permit,
to apply for a residence card
rather annual,
you will have to provide the 4 diplomas of the office.
This is provided for in Article L.
Quatre-cent-trente-trois,
indent 4 of the ccd